youth exclusion j'obtiens se retrouvent
sur bois rustique man épique j'ai
préparé google traduction c'est un écran
noir mère dessine un bonhomme alors le
principe du jeu est très simple on fait
des dessins et prennent littéralement
vie tout ce qui touche au dessin vous
plaît dans mes vidéos et moi aussi ça me
plaît alors c'est parti par contre à la
souris ce pas très pratique vous allez
faire des yeux orange c'est le matin il
a des cernes et la bouche
orange aussi puisque la bouche assez
fatigué le matin voilà à nouveau faire
le cran voilà je voulais pas un petit
peu plus de temps pour faire la main
c'est parti voilà je n'ai peut-être pas
dû prendre ce temps voilà il est pressé
partie à l'écart mon style et 6 a promis
aux mecs c'est génial je sais tout je le
crie au bonhomme bateau est décidément
une pote autant mais tu n'en déjà
beaucoup d'efforts en si peu de temps ok
alors déjà on va commencer par la tête
on va faire tous les cheveux oh là là on
demand [ __ ] d'araignée quoi et si sa
pote c'est une araignée ou pire à aa
je suis tout seul dans mon délire et
aucun problème samba voilà on se bat
entre dernier de nuit un nom dark spyder
aa pourquoi je suis seul dans ce délire
mais vous savez quoi regarder son fait
et bien moi ça j'arrive darksiders
auquel vient de se faire bouffer par un
livre je retrouve le livre et je dois
sauter dans le livre c'est ça je dois
trouver darksiders mais c'est tout et
depuis toujours
tout le monde le sait [ __ ] touche le
crillon feu et des signes du feu pour
brûler les obstacles
c'est enfin la poétesse pas brûler trop
mais c'est bien fait taisez vous on ne
veulent tenter vous le savez vous le
savez comme moi mais oui c'est une [ __ ]
magic a esquissé un sourire tout de
suite où je me vénère direct comment
joue ce portail allez va t-on vers un
portail à attendez je pense avoir deviné
quoi faire ça allume la mèche et ça va
péter beach si je fais un [ __ ]
d'incendié ce qu'on va mourir ou pas
voilà al oui ah tu as vu que du feu
salut jeune porte je veux pas juste ok
quoi plutôt que de brûler c'est
carrément carrément brutale quoi comme
technique des approches
bonjour madame tu a débloqué le passage
d'état tueur allons-y mais du coup y'a
pas de traduction à feurs donc toi tu
dégages attention quand même à will say
party deuxième niveau [ __ ] on a plein
on veut darksiders aux mondieux cette
dynamique d'état est une illuminati vous
avez vu ça aux mondiaux et attentes et
nous tuer était le chef des mines et
atypique tant il encore plus gros non
non mais son père dans un jeu comme ça
ça boume arrêté que je demandais mais
c'est interdit maintenant d'accord la
loi française à faire quelque chose
contre vous je crois avoir trouvé un
petit chemin secret darksiders [ __ ]
juste là oh mon dieu ce n'est pas la
seule personne avec un crayon magique
on a fait carrément à mons il protège
pas il débute en mai aux usa spider pig
la lame est ton venin sous sa peau peut
tu t'approches pas je te le dis tu
t'approches pas aller brûle hop là
regardez ils brûlent de
trop large à ben voilà il est décédé en
fin alors jackson on a du mal on est
heureusement j'ai l'impression elle
maintenant on se croit dans 30 des 10
pour le fait qu ils ont le bouffer à
débloquer le monstre de bono men stein
on a débloqué le crillon nuage dessine
un nuage pour faire pleuvoir décide un
nuage sont pour qu'elle la foudre ça
fait de leur âge c'est bon c'est parfait
je te combrit dénouer la part fallait
pas passer par là déjà
c'est l'électricité qui va le faire
vivre tatataaa j'ai juste fait griller
merde
ah mon dieu attend mail il faut il faut
il faut juste que j'ai pas sur quoi
allez décédé voilà écartez vous laissez
moi le chemin c'est moi le chemin quoi
petit oui mais espiègle à chaud on a dit
plus de jeux de mots qui en ont assez
sérieux alors pourquoi j'ai pas pensé
avant allait aller il ya des fers pour
tout le monde les seller très libre
merci a bientot à baromètre de l'orage
au dessus de ça tout simplement
et voilà monsieur alors forgan stein
télé tu as envie ou pas allez viens avec
moi
non c'est moi qui viens avec toi et ben
c'est pas grave oh mon dieu et dieu
merci frankenstein tu a débloqué la
caverne du mystère robotique
est-ce que c'est pas le moment à tout
hasard de refaire votre perso regardez
on dirait un [ __ ] la nasa c'est génial
m'aviez nul voilà il a qu'une grandes
jambes non non on peut le faire ça non
ça soit beau il ya des gens plus grosse
culotte c'est déjà pas mal
voilà ça c'est sa poche cd perdre nous
retrouverons darksiders à c'est là que
je dois faire des clés c'est ça j'ai
fait une clé à temps viendra couper mais
attends mais make me regarder à quoi il
ya tous les dangers du monde
ouf cette grille chic chic chic lâcher
quoi que tu te plait je mets dans le nez
tu as vu que du feu
ça marche pas à monsieur sanogo hévéa
intacte et jeux de mots non j'étais
contourner mon gars qui sue à faire le
coffre oui il fait quoi lui à ces bons
qui fait que mettre la clé dans son camp
je n'ai pas vu ça elle m'a trouvé garges
par higuain elle allait voilà que je
fasse quoi pour toi haye que je brûle
n'annonce pas loin de mourir en bas des
petits trucs cachés là j'aurais dû aller
dans la grotte qu'il voyait pas charger
la merde je veux rentrer à main mais
j'en aie
oui oui bien jouer tout à refaire tous
niveaux mais put franchement ça c'était
le niveau tutoriel voilà qui ont déjà
duré pas mal de temps ça suffit
maintenant à moi je veux jouer je veux
monter mon skill négatif au genre en
rien des lampes faire les nuages et les
clés attention il tombe par terre du
coup ça va nous faire un petit pont
grâce auquel vont pouvoir passer
tranquillement hier des locaux mis les
bêtes
oh le con non mais de l'autre côté se
plaît à yes
aïe ok j'ai pris le feu mais je me suis
pris dans le bus qui a pas rapprochés
quoi alors il faisait régner body voilà
qu'ubisoft mois la grotte je finisse
[ __ ] niveau tu a débloqué la grotte du
troll ouais super on y va tout de suite
il était infernal ce niveau c'est le cas
le député flamand
qu'est ce qui m'arrive ce jeu allons
donc
et arrête de te faire la grotte du troll
oh mon dieu faut couper des arbres vous
avez vu ça j'ai dessiné ce match voilà
c'est un bâton et sa coupe des arbres m
j'ai peur est ce que ça nous tue est
calé mais qu'elle ait au moins deux
qu'on à a mais c'est impossible
alors on va faire notre bonhomme on va
faire jumbo voilà c'est parti jumbo
alors là j'ai fait une hache mais l one
shot tout le monde regarde moi ça fait
vingt mètres j'ai compris vous voulez en
venir
on va couper ça ça va faire un bon ok
c'est luda luna attaque beau bordel
voilà esitpa casse bientôt c'est bien
mon grand allez bon courage wood a
survécu mon gars tu va débloquer la
bataille de bâton ville là je me fais
nash direct cela fait encore plus grande
que tout à l'heure voilà c'est un poing
américain mais pour géant ghoga regardez
regardez cette vilaine branche là elle
dégage bien sûr qu'elle dégage n'est pas
là mais j'ai vite hélas non je suis
bloqué je suis bloqué je suis bloqué les
pétales jour mogwai blogueurs des croix
pour défoncer mais va chier excusez moi
c'est un moyen pour moi d'évacuer la
pression voilà à l'aimer lui des petits
coups de boule
oui monsieur oui à les niveaux suivants
moi je vais retrouver darksiders s'il
vous plaît un homme plein prend une clé
va déverrouiller ça que ça fait ça ou
là-haut maintenant qu'on y est on ne peu
de choix monsieur a des cailloux qui est
un pur sprinter une grasse le bilan est
là je suis en mode veut pas de quart et
choqué respectez moi
respectez moi je suis un chat regardez
boum eh oui monsieur
aïe aïe
hi hi hi matic atchik atchik atchik hi
matic sa supportable au fake it [ __ ]
verges en peu plus d'un an je peux pas
je peux pas faut colton comme l'an passé
entre les deux passes entre les deux
atteint d'un tana nendaz olala c'est
beau ce qu'ont fait ou est sur dallas
les voilà mais d'où il sort celui là par
toi je me tire haye
n'as tu les vois tu dois seulement mais
[ __ ] jeunes relancer joué le jeu
j'avais quitté là je fais petite pause
de cinq secondes va passer en ni vu ni
ce n'est qu' un bon match
oh oui monsieur mais non mais je passe
comment là où je peux pas passer à l'eau
mais ça va encore attendre ça vaut quoi
moi voilà ça c'est moi et je prends ma
tête voiliers et puis j'avoue dans le
fond tu cèdes h binder non c'est pas la
joie la gombe renard est tout seul un
ferme
oui non non oui avant ioi là bas un
moyen laporte qui permet de s'évader
c'est ce qu'il ait marqué tout à l'heure
sous la pression je prends le haut pour
fêtes et bals rappelé également les
steaks disent nos consommateurs cette
vidéo met à savoir regarder ça m'a fait
craquer mon script comme un jeu sur deux
finalement sur cette chaîne youtube a eu
mes chevaux ils ont craqué au regard
d'éléments sont observées dans une
prochaine vidéo merci à vous regarder
tout le monde portez vous bien en pis
positive à m'adapter musique proposée à
l'essai la commissaire a compris c'est
la cokerie ouais c'est la complice et
accomplissez la poule